les nations africaines c'est une petite
coupe du monde
nous n'avons pas l'occasion de
de rêver de gagner des coupes du moins
alors une médaille d'or et la tirreno
groupe un peu vers l'europe verte
vraiment vers le haut et vers l'idéal
que nous recherchions à savoir gagner
les jeux olympiques brésil cameron c'est
parti pour une place en demi finale des
jeux olympiques
comme tombeau face au brésil au tout le
monde dit que bon c'est fini pour
s'arrêter là nous étions gonflé à bloc
mais on avait ronaldinho en face et dix
autres bonhomme
d'autres s'avèrent mobile le contrat qui
lie bangoura damian nolan équipe
ce sujet
et bonjour
nous avons joué à neuf pendant les trois
quarts du match et les brésiliens ont
égalisé pratiquement la dernière seconde
et vous voyez nous entamons les
prolongations
à neuf reprises il avance il y avait ce
qu'on appelait le but en or c'est à dire
20 les quelques marquer le premier but
c'est terminé le match s'arrête
tout le monde était de rénover pour
saluer le deuxième but du brésil qui
mettait fin au match
[Applaudissements]
se qualifier
et
je n'en revenais pas le monde entier n'a
et ça a été une année euphorique